متى تنتخب دون ليبيا وذلك سجلات سياسيه
وقانونيه لابد للامر من اليه وقاعده
دستوريه ذاك عينهما تراه حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الليبيه لكنها تريد اخضاع الامر
اولا للاستفتاء الشعبي
ما عندناش
الصوت عليه بنعم ولا لا
ونقولوا كنا لابد نصوت فيه ونقولوا يا هذا
الدستور يصلح فينا مش مكيفوني اجل عبد
الحميد ولا اجل عمر والله
هذا يصلح لليبيا ويصلح لمئه سنه كلامه
يسير عكس اتجاه المجلس الاعلى للدوله
بموافقته الخامسه على تعديل للاعلان
الدستوري يمهد لاجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه
التعديل الذي اقره مجلس النواب بالتشاور
مع مجلس الدوله حدد شكل السلطه التشريعيه
لكنه ترك شروط الترشح للرئاسه دون حسم اذ
لم يعالج الخلافه الجوهري حول ترشح
العسكريين ومزدوجي الجنسيه كخليفه حفتر
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
ثم الى التعديل لا يمكن ان يكون بديلا
لقاعده دستوريه ناظمه للانتخابات
لذلك وغيره بدا كان الممثل الخاص للامين
العام للامم المتحده في ليبيا قد يئس من
جدوى عمل المؤسسات الليبيه التي حكم عليها
بالفشل فعبد الله بتيلي يتجه لانشاء اليه
بديله تتمثل في لجنه تسيير رفيعه المستوى
للانتخابات في ليبيا وحدد للجنه مهمه
اعتماد اطار قانوني وجدول زمني ملزم
لاجراء الانتخابات خلال العام الحالي
او اذا سحب للبساط من تحت اقدام مجلسي
النواب والدوله بدعم امريكي وغربي
اصحاب هذا الراي سيجدون سندا في دعوه
واشنطن الفرقاء الليبيين الى الاصطفاف
وراء مبادره الموفد الاممي لكن يبدو ان
مصارعه مجلس الدوله للمصادقه على التعديل
الثالث عشر للاعلان الدستوري بمن حضر اعاد
كما يبدو خلط الاوراق
يجادل اعضاء في مجلس الدوله بعدم قانونيه
الجلسه لعدم توفر النصاب وينبه غيرهم الى
ان مجلس النواب نشر التعديل في الجريده
الرسميه قبل مصادقه مجلس الدوله عليه
بينما تسعى الامم المتحده لاستعاده زمام
المبادره تسعى قياده المجلسين الليبيين
كما يبدو للاحتفاظ باداره العمليه
السياسيه وفي اثناء ذلك يمضي الوقت دون ان
يصل البلد المنقسم سياسيا والمنهك
اقتصاديا وامنيا الى اخر محطات مراحله
الانتقاليه